it will be the biggest international
gathering the uk has hosted in decades
and a significant diplomatic moment
joining us now is to william haiti the
former british ambassador to afghanistan
and to saudi arabia hello to sir william
thank you for joining us
what an event it's going to be
indeed it's a
huge logistics challenge for the the
foreign off foreign commonwealth
development office it's a a huge day for
the prime minister and the foreign
secretary this is
uh although they're not going to be a
series of bilateral meetings there's
quite a lot of uh
i would liken it to speed dating it'll
be an opportunity for the prime minister
and the foreign secretary to meet
the whole galaxy of world leaders and
prime ministers
in a very short period of time so it's
it's an opportunity for the united
kingdom even even in her death
her majesty is is playing a significant
role in uh
in helping britain on the world stage
it's a challenge diplomatically isn't it
when we think about
russia we think about china we think
about saudi arabia
yes well it's uh obviously some
countries were not invited at all uh
russia and belarus who who
invaded a fellow european country
myanmar syria
iran in a sense obvious pariahs um other
countries the rest of the world with
whom we still have uh diplomatic
relations and
varying degrees of friendship um
they have they have been invited and
obviously
most people my understanding is that
nearly every country that was invited
has sent a representative um and that is
a mark of the respect in which the queen
is held personally
was held personally and it's an
important moment
although the de facto leader of saudi
arabia um will not be attending the
funeral he will have uh
a meeting to pay his respects with the
king um subsequently but we do know that
ukraine's first lady will be coming
yes well
it is answer not surprising that uh
ukraine would want to send as obviously
president zielinski can't leave the
battlefield as it were but but they will
want to be represented at a high a high
level as a mark of respect
out of out of both respect for her
majesty and for the support that the
united kingdom has given them in their
struggle against the russians
so william has there ever been a global
leader that has been so well respected
as her majesty
i can't think of one i was trying to
think last night you know
she was
recognized by everyone's but i mean i
spent a lot a lot of time in the gulf
where there are lots of monarchies and
the monarchies there
uh understood that
her majesty was the queen the monarch of
all monarchs that she was undisputed uh
leader of the monarchies if you like
given the longevity of both of her and
of the monarchy and of the way she
conducted herself
so i think
we will not see her like again britain
will not see her like again
because of the uh the way she conducted
herself and the the role she played in
promoting britain overseas she was
undoubtedly respected by uh
by
nearly everyone i ever encountered
have you
been privileged to meet her majesty
during her lifetime
i did i met her a few occasions i i was
with her when she hosted king abdullah i
met her on her first state visit to the
gulf of 1979 and i i had an audience
with her each time i took my leave of
her as ambassador and she was always
well informed about the country i was
going to i remember a particular story
when i was going as ambassador to sudan
she'd been to sudan in the 60s and
remembered with rajhuma being received
in sudan by a delegation which included
someone who introduced themselves as
head of your majesty's loyal communist
party that really tickled her and i i
remember that story
uh and a thought for
all those hundreds of thousands of
people that have stood in the cold in
order to pay their respects to the queen
well i'm in all of them you know uh they
all
it shows the the
deep love and respect and that they they
held for our majesty and they're kind of
representing all of us because some of
us haven't been able to make it there
and
pay our respects so they are kind of
representative of the whole nation
and giving her majesty this sort of
send-off that we all know she she
deserves